did you remain friendly with anyone from
Saturday Night Live or were there just
absolutely you did were you close with
Belushi and aoid even afterwards Danny
and I are very close you're still close
you get together socially oh sure you do
yeah why do I have this feeling you
didn't get along with these guys I
thought that there was a too much like
they were pissed off at you for leaving
Saturday Night Live you could have hurt
the show by leaving I thought there was
all this bad blood and they were angry
with you and they were all your friends
and you turned your back on I think
honestly if you were to
ask uh who's anybody who's left I mean
uh John and gild the God Rest their
souls but uh and they would say the same
I think if you talk to Jane or Lorraine
or right whoever you know Dan they' tell
you that that year that first year that
I was there was extremely close friendly
I was never a hard guy to work with or
anything like that I never took myself
seriously when it came to me getting
more famous it's later
on that that stuff gets into you and you
you keep thinking I have the perspective
I have the perspective I I'm old enough
to know not to be different a different
person right but you may not notice that
you're a little bit more self angr ising
or or whatever you know these and these
things are seen uh by people like John
or whatever uh as as a something else I
don't know but the fact is during the
time I was there it was just a very very
close close nit group and I did a lot of
the writing I was hired as the
headwriter uh at the beginning right uh
it changed around with Michael donu and
others but basically um I did everything
I could to write people into update for
instance Lauren didn't have a big part
I'd write her in a remote at the Blain
Hotel you wer self in you were happy to
yes and the whole cast was happy I mean
Garrett would tell you that too and so
there was never that's why it took me by
surprise coming back and hearing that
John had told stories um I I didn't know
what he could have told because you were
shocked yeah because now people I know
who work on Saturday life say everybody
has writes their own material nobody
shares with anybody it's like a
cutthroat
yeah so it was a different way back then
it was like you guys were cab so few of
us right but if you but if you wrote
something good you might even say gee
this isn't right for me it's right for
someone else I wrote Jaws to right which
was the the land shark concept I thought
John does a great Richard dyus you know
Danny's Great in anything and I'll do
the shark CU I can do this guy who goes
uh Mrs Allan you know you know shark the
concept was the shark the shark's really
intelligent he's a land shark but really
not a hell of a lot brighter uh than the
people who open the door and they're not
real bright nobody's really bright in
any of this so he say uh uh flowers ma'
well I I'm not expecting any flowers and
there'd be a little pause and I'd go um
your cars double pared you know anything
oh in that case they open the door just
sitting around what could be funny Jaws
was popular I'm going to write I lik the
character of the shark too I I I think I
want to do that voice yeah that the
sharks can talk that he can talk would
you sketch this by hand or would you
type it on you would type it out yeah I
have the original typed thing in my
house
actually